hace un día de muchísimas acusaciones y
muchísimas presiones de la familia y del
entorno de alexéi navalni para que las
autoridades rusas por fin permitiese que
el disidente ruso fuese evacuado a
alemania finalmente al caer la tarde
aquí en rusia los médicos del hospital
permitieron que alexéi navalni fuese
tratado en el hospital xanit de berlín
por cierto que en este centro
hospitalario algo de experiencia tiene
porque ya trataron en el pasado a pie
otros ver si love otro disidente ruso
que también fue envenenado la de hoy es
una doble victoria para el equipo y la
familia de aleccionaban y porque allí va
a ser tratado con más garantías con
mejor equipamiento sanitario y también
porque ahí se podrá llevar a cabo una
investigación seria e imparcial sobre
cuáles han sido exactamente las
circunstancias de este misterioso
envenenamiento que casi cuesta la vida
alexéi navalni